[Music]
welcome everyone to this big sofa event
of this month's iii live and i'm
delighted today to house my guest ian
mcgillcrist to talk about one of the key
themes of his new book
the matter with things our brains our
delusions
and the unmaking of the world thanks
very much alexis
one of the key themes of your new book
that i'd like to talk to you about today
is that reality isn't made of things
but my common sense seems to tell me
otherwise right the world looks to me to
be made very much of things to be made
of tables and chairs and my laptop that
i'm looking at now and people and trees
and then on the other hand we have
physics that tells us or seems to tell
us that the world that at its most
fundamental level is made out of
particles
out of forces and fields so what's wrong
with those two pictures of reality
there's nothing wrong with the idea of
things i'm very content that people
should go on thinking there are things
and treating them as such
but ultimately i believe that all is in
process that as heraclitus said
everything flows
and i'm a follower of a.n whitehead
who of course was a process philosopher
and i also hold the slightly
um
perhaps at the outset rather paradoxical
sounding view
that
relationships are prior to the relata
that what primarily exists is relations
relationships
and things are what emerge from this
network it's perfectly okay to to see
them as things and to focus on them and
all that but it's just not the best way
of thinking about composing a view of
the cosmos that it's made up of things
rather as a body is not actually made up
of organs that are developed and then
connected to one another
the whole organism
comes into being by the differentiation
into the organs that can later
after the fact be identified as parts
can you tell us a little bit about what
led you to this position of thinking of
the world as
being primarily made out of relations
not things
well is it's something that i suppose
has come to me rather gradually over a
long time i i suppose i've been thinking
about this sort of thing for 50 years
or more
um
and
right at the beginning of those 50 years
i thought that
the whole was not the same as the sum of
the parts and you couldn't necessarily
put something together in the way that
you can take it apart so that's always
been part of my
um my philosophical outlook on the world
the the idea that things are
relationships follows
partly from that in that
um not just an organism as we would
normally think of it but
a piece of music
is not better understood by taking it
apart note by note but is in fact a
seamless web of relations
and it's that seamless web of relations
that is real
so as you mentioned before there's
something quite radical about your
position in that you see relations as as
fundamental as kind of prior to the
things that are related
and you say somewhere that
the things that are related only become
what they are
in and through the relationships they
belong to precisely it's the context
that makes them what they are exactly
now you admit that this position is
can seem at least paradoxical right it
poses the question of
how we really can make sense of
relations without already having in view
the very things that are supposed to be
related so how do you avoid this
apparent paradox
well i don't think it's difficult
as you say and this has been again a
lifelong
concern certainly since my twenties when
i was first at all souls
and looking at the way we approached
works of art poems and so forth it
seemed to me that
one of the problems was the idea that um
we took things out of context as soon as
you start sitting in the seminar room
you begin the process of
disembodying abstracting removing from
context making the unique general and
making the implicit explicit all of
these working in
the exact opposite direction to the one
in which the work itself is trying to
lead you and i think that that's not
something peculiar about art it's
something about life and that
art and poetry and so on are just
examples of organic beings as aristotle
indeed thought they were and
not examples of mechanisms or um
building blocks
and you you do say that
sort of seeing the world as made of
things as part of
this kind of reductionist picture that
much of science operates under and the
idea that
in order to understand
the nature of something we need to
understand its parts and the mechanics
of those parts and
you accept that this approach has made
science extremely successful at allowing
us to manipulate the world around us to
predict it to create new technology
yes
now realists often see this argument as
basically showing that science gets to
the truth of what the world is like and
the argument is look it works it allows
us to do all these things that no other
picture of reality allows us to do
so why is the ability to manipulate the
world's not proof in your view that
science actually understands the world
what exactly is science missing here
ask the sources apprentice who knew
exactly how to press the button but
didn't really understand what he was
doing
i think there's something similar here
there are two points really i mean the
first one i ought to make is that
you've idealist or naive realist i
insist that as it were
we take part in reality but we don't
simply ground it or originate it so
whatever reality we encounter has
something of us about it but it also has
something that is not us about it and
it's in that encounter that we we find
reality
um in our experience
so
that's the first thing i suppose and the
other is that
when you have a very complex system
um
and sometimes i have a slide that
illustrates a massively complex system
in which there are arrows leading from
just about everything to everything else
there are little areas if you focus in
on them
where there's a chain of causation and
it's not that complicated and you can
intervene in it and you would no doubt
have a predictable result by doing so
but if you were asked a different
question not how to manipulate the world
but how to understand it you couldn't
understand it by just putting together
linear sequences because that wouldn't
answer to the complexity of what you're
dealing with
and as
you probably know and anyone who's read
either of those books would know
i believe the result depth of the left
hemisphere is to manipulate the world
it's to be a very good aid to the
business of grabbing and getting
precisely what you want at the time
but just because it does that it's not
very good at understanding and that is
really the forty of the right hemisphere
and this is why the two hemispheres
are asymmetrical and only partially
connected at all uh only two percent of
fibers across the corpus callosum the
band of fibers at the base of the brain
and a lot of that traffic is inhibitory
in saying i'm dealing with this uh you
keep out of it so
you know it's it's a complex thing
what's going on in our in our brains and
our minds and it's not simply um good
enough to say well because i can
intervene in a causal chain and create
some and have a certain kind of outcome
it is something rather made on the uh
model of the bike in the garage that's
put together from bits what's the proof
what's the criterion by which we can be
sure that we understand something rather
than just able to
kind of causally interfere with it if
you understand
better the the structure of reality you
will be less often caught out by
experience so in other words
it's a test on experience effectively
and the lovely thing that i can
demonstrate and do at some length in
this new book about 400 pages length of
the book
is to look at what happens when the
right hemisphere is not functioning and
the answer is the left hemisphere simply
doesn't understand the world i mean it's
it really is as simple as that
it's the almost all delusional states
hallucinations
um
misjudgments
it simply can't read people for a start
it doesn't understand emotional and
social communication and that it's
somewhat autistic
um if you like to look at it that way
nonetheless the the structure of reality
is not changed but when the right
hemisphere is damaged it is changed i
think it's fairly conclusive
let me ask you
something on this because a lot of your
work
originates in sort of neuroscience
research and
sometimes you bring examples from
theoretical physics to support your
claims but here you've been talking a
lot about this
um
you know what we learned by how we
understand the left hemisphere and the
right hemisphere and how they contribute
very different things to our
cognitive relationship to the world
exactly but is there a tension there
with within your own philosophy as it
were because on the one hand
you seem to be arguing for
the limits of scientific understanding
the way that science is reductionist and
it only offers us a very narrow
understanding of reality the world
ourselves but on the other hand it seems
like you're using the findings of
scientific research to ground your own
picture of what
science is sort of missing out so
absolutely how do you negotiate that
tension
extraordinarily easily i'm a great
admirer of science i've studied science
all my life it was my first passion as a
child my father and my grandfather were
scientists and that was what i was
introduced to
and i
argue rationally
all the way through my writing and
people say you make it very clear and
you use all these things like science
and reason
how come well the answer is because i
think they're very valuable i just don't
think that reason can account for
everything any more than i think science
can
there's nothing irrational about
listening to mozart's g minor quintet
it's just super irrational
trans-rational
not encompassable
let me ask you about something you
mentioned earlier when it came to
um
understanding life
non-reductively
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you